the question about having a role model
so again as I just say it's not going
from young age but there are few people
that I admire him signs very few in one
of them is Ludwig Boltzmann that I hold
in very high regards regardless of the
fact that he committed suicide at the
end but it so he is the guy who kind of
invent statistical mechanics a he is the
guy who figure out what is entropy well
everybody has got it for me they woke of
heat engines he figure out how it works
on molecular level and he had a lot of
detract also claims that he is wrong it
did not necessarily influence his career
I don't know if you got no bail or not
but he was very important professor and
very original single so I think I put
him at the highest so he is in some
respect role model like many time where
I give seminars and I try to explain how
enzymes work and how they do not work I
put his photo as example of what
actually it at which direction you have
to look though I mean he is buried
interests and I Saturday held that is
good when I teach chemistry I forced the
students to draw his picture for one
point so have a hormone